WWE fans from around the world were
chanting no no no when Daniel Bryan
announced his retirement from the world
of wrestling I'm Kate and this is your
gamespot news update former WWE World
Heavyweight Champion Daniel Bryan has
announced his retirement via Twitter
Brian's career was at an all-time high
when he lost the strength in his right
arm in May 2014 after winning both the
WWE and world heavyweight championships
at WrestleMania 30 he had to forfeit the
titles to undergo neck surgery he would
return to WWE the next year to win the
Intercontinental title but it wouldn't
be long before an unknown injury
required him to relinquish his title a
second time the injury was eventually
disclosed as concussion related though
Brian was cleared by doctors at UCLA the
WWE was hesitant to do so themselves
Bryan's career was known to be at risk
and that a return to professional
wrestling was very unlikely aside from
medical reasons not much is known about
what exactly his bush Bryan to retire he
closed monday's episode of Raw by
addressing his retirement expressing
gratitude towards his fans and joining
them for one last yes chant will you
miss the yes movements glorious
pint-sized leader do you think his
retirement is probably for the best
given his catalogue of concussions let
me know in the comments or come and find
me on Twitter I'm at how not to draw
thanks for watching and for all your
entertainment and wrestling news keep it
gamespot